,
chercheure associée
à l'Observatoire sur le Moyen-
Orient  de la Chaire Raoul-
Dandurand, à l'UQAM.
Bonsoir.
- Bonsoir.
- Les  Iraniens continuent
de manifester au péril de leur
vie. Pourquoi le cas particulier
de Mahsa Amini provoque-t-il
autant de colère?
- Écoutez, je pense que la
population iranienne est arrivée
une forme de maturité politique
est arrivée un ras le bol
généralisé. Ce que vous voyez
ici, c'est vraiment je pense
résultats de plus de 40 ans de
répression de mesures
gouvernementales, de mesures
religieuses, de mesure stricte
qui commença étouffer cette
population. Dans le cas de cette
jeune fille de 22 ans, un peu
plus en fait aujourd'hui
accepter l'inacceptable. Je
pense que aujourd'hui, de dire
non et de ne plus acptpter ce
type de pratique.
Malheureusement,asasha Amini
fait parti d'une longue suite de
pratiques. Alors je vous parle,
lui accorder victime.
- Tous les jours, ces jeunes
manifestent au péril de leur
vie, lrérépression et terrible.
- Prendre la parole, critiquer
l'État c'est vraiment au prix de
votre vie. Le danger est
partout. Évidemment il y a une
insécurité. Là où l'État devrait
garantir la sécurité, la paix,
c'est plutôt la menace, de la
sécurité qui règne. C'est un
état qui est sous contrôle est
sous surveillance en permanence.
Aucun espace si vous voulez
délaisser la critique, au
dialogue ce type de
revendication ce qui est de
tordre plus intéressant c'est
qu'on voit en fait arriv a au
devant de la scène des droits
humains et les droits des femmes
parce que c'est aussçaça le cas
de Masha Amini.
- Est-ce que ce sont des
manifestations contre le port du
voile grattoir la police des
moeurs sont devenus des
manifestations contre le régime
tout simplement?
- Les manifestations se
croisent. Pour la femme, c'est
de lutter contre l'ensemble des
droits a l'égard des femmes.
Le code vestimentaire fait
partie de l'une de ces mesures
très strictes imposées aux
femmes. Ce type de revendication
de rejoindre d'autres types de
revendications d'ordre
démocratique. Liberté
d'expression, je pense aussi que
les Iraniens demandent ce que
l'État prenne et qu'il puisse
pour une fois assurée peu être
le contrat social, ce contrat
social n'a jamais été respecté.
L'État, après plus de 40 ans de
règne, la situation économique
est désastreuse. Espace
politique est fermé.
Les questions sociales. Le bien-
être est simplement plus
garanti. Ajoute la réponse de
l'État qu'il y a une réponse
forte et brutale en violencestst
nationalisé a tous les niveaux
de la société.
- Est-ce que ces manifestations
vont finir par ébranler le
pouvoir pas?
- Ce que ça démontre que le
régime ne sembles-tu avoir de
légitimité, il n a a plus de
imité aujourd'hui. Ça démontre
une rupture entre la société et
l'État.
- Il y a un décalage entre la
société qui veut plus de
liberté, plus de démocratie.
- Absolument, c'est une
population qui est éduquée.
Iraniens demandent depuis très
longtemps un processus de
démocratisation. C'est pour
lutter contre les lois
discriminatoires contre les
femmes. Ces femmes qui ont lutté
contre le port obligatoire du
voile en Iran et j'en passe. Il
y a eu normalement de campagnes
de mutation d'action collective,
la protestation des
revendications. Malheureusement,
on voit que chaque fois qu'il y
a ce type de manifestations dans
l'espace public, mais aussi dans
l'espace spirituel, la
répression et la réponse donnée
par l'État.
- Est-ce qu'il y a quelque chose
de particulier dans cette équipe
donner un certain espar, que
peut être ébranlée d'une
certaine façon.
- J'aimerais vous dire oui.
J'aimerais y croire comme je
pense beaucoup d'Iraniens
souhaite qu'il y ait un
véritable changement,
malheureusement si on fait le
bilan des autres mouvements de
protestationonon voit qu'à
chaque fois même si
malheureusement il y a eu cet
élan, sentiment de révolte, ce
risque les uns et les autres
prennentococument de leur vie,
malheureusement on voit que ce
mouvement est écrasé étouffer.
- Il est comme un écho assez
manifestations comme ce soir
Montréal et ça, est-ce que c'est
important de mettre de la
pression sur le régime?
- C'est important parce que ça
démontre ce fait entre l'Iran et
l'extérieur. Parfois les
Iraniens peuvent se sentir
isolés. Déjà ce pays isolé au
niveau national. Parfois la
population iranienne se sont
oubliées. Cette de mobilisation
vient rappeler que non, on n'est
pas beaucoup de pays
aujourd'hui, des pays
occidentaux et aussi les
communautés iraniennes et faire
du pays mais pas la démocratie.
Cette forme de solidarité
nécessaire de savoir ce "nous"
passe en ce "eux" passe un ce
les taxe mobilise.
- Merci beaucoup d'être venu
nous en parler.  p pense que
c'est important d'être venu en
faire le point e